what's popping soups it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler Show
genv episode 4 has introduced quite the
intense and unique character with reveal
that VA hero Tech Knight has been
dispatched to find someone to take the
fall for Golden Boy golden shower all
over the pavement but just who is this
newest character to be adapted from the
original boys comics and are his Hobbies
as invasive in the comics as they were
to that innocent Tree in gen V today we
shall investigate all things Tech Knight
together my nerd babies and spoiler
warning for the character of tech Knight
in the boy comic series because we're
going to be talking about all the key
elements of his life from that Source
material so if you somehow still need a
spoiler warning on a channel called
heavy spoilers there it is you're
welcome all right so the version of tech
Knight that we meet in Amazon's gen V is
significantly different than the one we
see in the comics in a lot of ways in
the show for example Tech Knight berates
Dean Shetty for being just a human while
he himself was an exceptional superhero
with heightened super senses is powered
by compound V not so much in the comics
when he first appeared in the boys Issue
7 tech knite is actually revealed to
have no powers whatsoever as he was
originally meant to be a mishmash of a
parody that mixed Marvel's Iron Man with
the DC characters Batman and Starman as
the real life name for DC Starman is
actually Ted Knight and the reason Tech
Knight is called the tech Knight in the
comics is because of all the technology
that surrounds his very fragile and very
human body in the form of a massive blue
Iron Man style Su suit this being the
case Tech Knight is of course not his
real name in the comics despite him
mainly going by Tech Knight in gen v
he's actually a dude by the name of
Robert Vernon a guy who became the tech
Knight to follow in the footsteps of the
knights who came before him two previous
Knights that were originally called the
steel Knight with Robert changing the
name from steel Knight to Tech Knight
when he became the third person to hold
the mantle in a more technologically
advanced age but whether or not the tech
Knight that we see in gen V has any sort
of past as a super armored Hero has yet
to be seen the character the legend
mentions one of these steel Knights of
the past in season 3 episode 5 when he
brags about getting Marlon Brando to cut
his quote from the steel Knight movie
anyway after that I got Marlon to cut
his quote on that steel Knight picture
so another comic element from Tech
Knight's history that has yet to be seen
in live action is his kid sidekick ladio
who's very much meant to be the robin to
Tech Knights Batman and because of this
parody ltio would end up changing his
name to swing wi just like Robin changes
his name to Nightwing in DC Comics but
uh Tech Knight don't talk to his former
sidekick that much these days and
there's a very specific reason for that
that you could probably guess because
you see in the comics Tech Knight used
to be part of a group of superheroes
called payback who were a parody of the
Avengers and they were the second most
popular group of superheroes after the
seven in that universe and I say used to
be part of payback because uh they had
toh suspend him from the team not
because he couldn't carry his weight as
a corporate hero but primarily because
of his Unholy mental illness manifesting
at the wrong place and the wrong time
with that wrong place and time being in
midair while heading home after a
superhero Mission because while the
members of payback were all flying home
after doing their Duty Tech Knight was
eyeing to Bone one of his teammates
booties his robotic colleague by the
name of the Mind Droid who was the
comics parody of Marvel's vision and
unfortunately Tech Knight would try to
make those lustful thoughts of reality
right then and there when he tried to
enter his first hole in midair telling a
psychiatrist like later on in his life
that he didn't even know why he did it
just that his compulsion to get silly
with his Willie in every hole in the
city started that day you know right
before he violated that psychiatrist cat
not even joking like the therapist dude
left the room for literally 2 seconds
and Tech Knight just could not help
himself from chasing [__] cat holes so
yeah needless to say that was Tech
Knight's last day in therapy dude has
issues man and this is kind of a bummer
considering that this guy truly does not
know why he was cursed to live that life
and was genuinely seeking answers from a
mental health professional but hey he
did try to cream another man's cat so
you know them's the rules can't really
do that in therapy these days because
everyone is woke now or something I
don't know just kidding don't don't do
that that's uh very wrong but this
brings us to another major difference
between the comic and the liveaction
tech Knights because while the
liveaction tech Knight is well aware of
his brain tumor that is triggering all
of these Unstoppable urges comic book
Tech Knight literally had no idea where
the hell this r R urge to stick his dick
in pits even came from and never would
have the chance to find out before his
tragically hilarious death but more on
that later but anyways ever since that
incident with the Mind Droid Tech Knight
has had the compulsion to violate every
attractive hole that comes within his
eyeline even telling his temporary
therapist that he stuck his junk inside
of a sight of beef the holes within his
cave Hideout and even his own niece's
chinchilla a chinchilla that his sister
and his niece caught him trying to bury
in the backyard to hide the evidence so
you know needless to say his sister
doesn't talk to him anymore nor does she
allow him to see his niece and I'm
pretty sure he's banned from every Petco
Nationwide but another person that does
not talk to Tech Knight anymore is his
former sidekick ladio because those two
have some really awkward history because
Tech Knight wasn't technically a sexual
deviant by choice he was super concerned
that his brain disorder would lead him
into making lao's booty hole quite sadio
so Tech Knight decided to make up a
completely [__] quest for l IO to
train with every single superhero group
that ladio could find under the guise of
wanting to make ladio stronger but he
actually just wanted to keep ladio
cavities from his sexual depravity a
quest ladio took on Happily without
question because let's face it ladio was
kind of dumb but I'm sure that getting
rid of his old trusty sidekick was quite
sad for Tech Knight because before he
got really sick he and ladio would fight
all sorts of crime together and would
repeatedly play a game of cat and mouse
with their sometimes friend sometimes
foe Talon who is a clear parody of DC's
Catwoman and Batman's relationship with
Catwoman and this being the case
eventually Talon became very close
friends with both Tech Knight and swing
wi over the years so close in fact that
one night while Tech Knight and Talon
were hanging out together Talon
convinced Tech Knight to call swing-wing
over and then later convince both of
them to play a rousing game of pin the
tail on the Talon with her a threesome
crossover event that proved to be so
traumatizing to Tech Knight that he and
swing-wing pretty much stopped talking
completely afterwards as both both of
those dudes were unfortunately extremely
homophobic people and couldn't handle
what they've done together because
despite Tech Knight having fantasized
about engaging in sexual acts with men's
holes in the past that was mainly a side
effect of his brain tumor's fascination
with holes you know like that one time
he stuck his Tech pecker into his own
Butler's ear holes causing his Butler to
immediately quit and reveal Tech
Knight's unhinged sexual behavior to the
media as he should that's kind of gross
however Tech Knight was not attracted to
his Butler at all but was merely drawn
to the hole of his ear but that of
course did not matter to Thomas the
butler or any of those newspapers who
ran Thomas's Story by painting the
heavily homophobic Tech Knight as a gay
man which technically was not true and
this new story would of course CA Tech
Knight's superhero career and all the
respect that came with it to vanish in a
near instant until one day after he
saved a woman from a gruesome death from
a falling wheelbarrow a massive meteor
started hurling its way towards the
planet threatening all of life and
causing all the boys at Nasa to freak
the hell out at Humanity's imminent
demise but have no fear Tech Knight the
ear poker is here with tech Knight
giving hope to all the people at NASA's
mission control by saying the brave
words gentlemen if it's got a hole I can
[__]
it and so Tech Knight flew into outer
space put his pener inside of the meteor
and shot his organic payload inside of
that very meteor causing the giant rock
to explode at the cost of tech Knight's
life with the entire world regarding
Tech Knight as a hero once more which
would have made a really dope Redemption
for Mr Knight if that actually happened
turns out all of that meteor stuff was
just a hallucination courtesy of a
collaboration between Tech Knight's
brain tumor and the falling wheelbarrow
that he saved that lady from because the
wheelbarrow actually landed right on
Tech Knight's exposed Tech Noggin and
during his last moments his brain
imagined the whole meteor scenario up so
that Tech Knight would feel like he died
as a hero who is fully accepted by
Humanity but in reality everyone still
saw him as a loser who liked to put his
dick in things and it wouldn't be until
Tech Knight's autopsy that a tumor the
size of an adult fist was found inside
of his brain revealing to everyone the
true source of tech Knight's horrific
lifestyle but yeah that's basically
comic book Tech Knight in a tech
nutshell just a dude with a brain tumor
inside of a super suit I am super
interested to see how Tech Knight's
character evolves in this liveaction
universe because I kind of want to find
out if he has an Iron Man as supersuit
or if he became a detective type hero
solely based on his superpowered
perception because having a name like
Tech Knight without any of the actual
Tech or the Knighthood would kind of be
super weird in my opinion so I hope to
see more of this awfully odd man very
soon in gen V or in the next upcoming
season of the boys because I for one am
looking forward to learning a whole lot
more about him get it see what I did
there I said a-hole cuz cuz he likes
a-holes okay I'm done anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow Me @ mentertainment on
Twitter and Instagram or wherever I am
on the social medias but most
importantly you can follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and on Twitter
and wherever he is on the internet cuz
Paul is an amazing man who makes amazing
breakdowns and you don't want to miss
any of the videos that either me or Paul
make especially all of Paul's breakdowns
on both gen Z and the Ahsoka series and
hey if you like the video why not just
take a quick second and drop a like it's
a really small thing but it really helps
out the channel got to love that YouTube
algorithm but yeah thanks again for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye